over 1994 when we were only about four
months away from meeting our contractual
deadline to finish the manuscript the
republicans swept to victory this was
certainly in a historical moment for the
first time in 40 years the republicans
were in charge of the House and the
Senate the contract with america was on
everyone's lips everyone was talking
about newt gingrich the the political
world had shifted dramatically but there
we were George and I exhausted fed up
with a book and with a finish line in
sight we were determined not to let this
dramatic change affect our book too much
you know we said okay sure will will
beef up the last chapter and we'll do
something more with the prologue in the
introduction and you know maybe make
that last chapter a very special chapter
but early in the year was clear to our
publisher certainly and most of our
friends that something had to be done I
remember I was sitting in the Senate
press gallery one morning and David
Rogers from The Wall Street Journal
walked over and said so I was the
outcome of the election going to affect
your book I said oh no problem I mean
we're just going to you know tinker on
the margins and you know we'll probably
do you know a big last chapter one big
chapter to deal with it and there was
his paws and he said one chapter and
there's he raised his eyebrows had a
shirt is one chapter as if to say hey
bub get serious there's more work in
your future than that that July times
books confirmed those suspicions and and
we were told we had to write an entirely
different book that focus on the
Republican revolution and what it was
doing to the budget they like everyone
else was confident that there was going
to be a balanced budget agreement I
guess we didn't fully appreciate it that
at the time that the republican takeover
was really a blessing in disguise it was
certainly a much better story to report
and it made for a much better book while
we were concerned that all of our years
of research and we spent a lot of time
delving into
supply-side economics back in the early
80s after Reagan took over and and and
the impact of Reagan's policies and and
the defense build-up and scores of other
factors in creating the the big modern
era deficits that politicians were
struggling with we looked into that
George was very interested in the
nineteen ninety budget summit which was
the last time there was a major effort
by Republicans and Democrats to try to
do something about the deficit although
it cost President Bush dearly we had
spent a lot of time looking into all
these these stories and they were
fascinating stories and we were
concerned that suddenly we're going to
have to jettison all that work and just
do a book on the Republican revolution
as interesting as that was but as we got
into it more deeply we realized that to
understand what was going on today we
really had to understand the history of
this and so all of that research became
the spine of the book and all that
history was very important but what we
had to do as journalists was to look at
all that through the prism of what was
happening this year 1995 1996 and as
writers this is perhaps the the most
important lesson that we learned that it
wasn't enough just to interview you know
hundreds of people and and read history
books and debrief people on meetings and
stuff like that all that stuff's
important but in the end you basically
had to take that material in hand and do
something with it massage it use it to
drive your notions of deficit politics
and in the end if you can do that you
can tell a much larger story as I say
remarkably most of the issues we began
to deal with in 1995 simply echo the
issues that we had been studying before
we ran into the Republican revolution
and a determined publisher who wanted a
very different very different book and
all those events became the backdrop for
what unfolded in 1995 when determined
Republican Party took over and tried to
impose its vision
on washington in the rest of the country
newt gingrich dick armey Tom DeLay and
others mistakenly we think thought that
they they were dealing with a a
wishy-washy kind of wimpish Democratic
president the Republicans came in
believing that they could make President
Clinton bow to them through the threat
of closing down the government if
necessary and it's interesting they the
Republicans did sort of a personality
profile of the president shortly after
they took office much as the FBI would
sort of do a profile of a serial killer
or something like that just sort of
going back and figuring the guy out and
their conclusion was in the face of a
threat and shut down the president would
cave okay thank you it was a huge drama
that culminated in the high-profile
budget talks at the White House that
eventually collapsed in January of 1996
and what was so interesting and so
ironic was that Clinton emerged from the
wreckage looking masterful and the
Republicans were confused and
demoralized one of the reasons we wanted
to do this book was that we saw that the
Republicans had fallen victim to the
same trap that hidden sneered many who
came before them I think the popular
attitude toward Washington's deficit
problem was that it would be easy to fix
it you know if only those idiots in
Washington could get their acts together
I mean what's the problem Bill Clinton
came to Washington thinking the same
thing he had been governor and Arkansas
and he had balanced the budget of course
there was a law that made it a crime for
him not to and of course the pressures
were much different but he was he was
confident that you know within the year
or two he could with that budget into
shape they were all sort of seduced by
the notion that they were smarter than
anyone else that they could fix what no
one else could I think one of our our
favorite examples of this was Ross Perot
who had declared during the nineteen
ninety-two presidential campaign
that he he had a simple plan that would
fix the deficit we were so taken with
this guy's amazing hubris and his
precipitous fall when it turned out he
hadn't the slightest idea what he was
talking about I mean we talked to some
of his people who helped him put
together his grand schemes for balancing
the budget and they were always saying
after meetings with Ross they scratched
their head and said you know how could
this guy know so little about the budget
and yet pretend to know so much and
we're so taken with us that the original
title for the book was not mirage but it
was without breaking a sweat which was
something that Perot used to say as in
hey I can fix that but you know that
deficit without breaking a sweat
actually George does a much better
imitation of ross perot than i did and
he amused me many nights while we were
working on this on this book of his with
his invitation yes he did and that was a
one o'clock in the morning what may have
been funny at one o'clock we thought it
was hilarious a woman I'm gonna skip
that tonight other thing that the thing
that we found over now I knew that'd be
a popular decision the thing I found
over and over and over again was it
wasn't just Ross Perot it's almost
anybody with a big ego who comes to
Washington and they see you know that
problem isn't so difficult i mean ronald
reagan came and he said I can handle
this he promised to balance the budget
and he said it's going to be easy in
fact it was fairly destructive the way
he framed it for all his successors
because he said this is really easy all
you have to do is cut fraud waste and
abuse and go after welfare queens and so
on and Bengal you solved the problem but
as Eric points out the best example in
our book of a guy who really thought he
could handle this was was Bill Clinton
who had told his associates when he was
governor of Arkansas you know this
doesn't this is not rocket science this
is not that difficult if I can do it in
Arkansas why can't the federal
government do it in Washington and
nobody learned more painfully just one
of our favorite parts of the book and
why I wrote the 147 page chapter 22 show
this is he calm seas a brand new
president 1993 he's convinced by a
variety of people that the one thing
he's got to do before I can do anything
else is to come up with a serious
deficit reduction program and remember
this isn't balancing the budget this is
just cutting the deficit in half over
four years
so he brings this thing to a Congress
which by the way is a Democratic
Congress first Democratic president in
12 years you'd think it'd be a fairly
friendly venue for him to go to and he
has what even some of his sympathetic
colleagues called a near-death
experience he came within a single vote
in both the House and the Senate of
losing this thing I'll Gore had to go up
to Capitol Hill twice to break ties in
the Senate and if Marjorie Margolies
miss Vince key hadn't essentially
sacrificed her career to vote for this
thing he would have lost it it's very
very difficult to do and it was this
kind of a story that convinced this week
maybe there's some compelling stories
here let me just digress for a second
and say that when you're writing a book
I don't know how many other authors have
had this experience it's great when
you're in a conversation because people
always say so what are you up to lately
and you say well I'm writing a book and
and they say really and the light kind
of goes on in their face and they say
what's it about unfortunately Eric and I
would have to say well it's about the
budget deficit and then before we could
explain that it's really a compelling
fascinating story they'd say oh really
you know I think I left the stove on but
good luck with that book about the
deficit yeah it of course there is this
this widespread and absolutely incorrect
notion that the budget is dull anybody
who would like us has covered it for
years and years we wouldn't be doing
this we're not crazy it's actually at
very compelling this is where the nation
obviously to mean to be grand about it
works out the clashes of the strongly
held beliefs and also the people are get
to fight about this especially in
Washington are some of the best and most
interesting politicians you'll find
anywhere this provokes great stuff great
often great drama one of our favorite
scenes in the book that used to be at
the beginning of the book until the
republicans took over the congress in 94
and forced us to rewrite it was this eve
mundane Rostenkowski who was before he
was a federal prisoner was a the
chairman of the House Ways and Means
Committee and he went in August of 1989
home to Chicago to his congressional
district to defend something called the
Medicare catastrophic coverage hacked
and for anybody who doesn't remember
what that is I'll give you a small and
over simplified explanation it expanded
Medicare coverage but in exchange there
was a surtax paid mostly theoretically
by wealthier people
and at the time a lot of people in the
country got that got the idea that they
were going to have to pay this tax even
if they were middle class people who at
whom the tax was not aimed and it became
a very unpopular enormously unpopular
and controversial program a lot of
interest groups going to fan the flames
and misinform people and anyway
Rostenkowski goes back in the middle of
this atmosphere a very angry atmosphere
to his home district in Chicago during
the August recess and he's trying to
explain this he's not making any headway
he's a senior center in downtown Chicago
and he decides I gotta get out of here
and he goes out to his car where his
drivers waiting a big Ford or Caprice
and he jumps in and he tells the driver
get me out of here and unfortunately in
the time it took him to get into the car
that protesters have surrounded the car
and they've taken their placards which
say things like liar and impeach and
rotten kowski and jerk and also to can
get an idea of the tenor of this
proceeding and they're starting to beat
on the car and a woman named Leona
coziness nice woman with heart-shaped
glasses who's never done anything like
this before in her life crawls up on the
hood of the car and pretty soon she's
got her face right up against the
windshield and she's eyeball to eyeball
with Rostenkowski who's not a small man
he was a large sometimes very
intimidating guy but cozy and later told
reporters she said you know I was scared
but I could tell looking at his eyes he
was even more scared than I was and he
jumps out of the car and runs down the
street and you can imagine this thing
it's all caught on TV dan rostenkowski
running down the street in these
protesters waving their placards saying
yeah bomb you're wired get out of here
this was the kind of thing that we
thought if we could write a book like
this it might actually work but I think
it was the the poignant moments that
haunted us the motion in writing the
book Bob Dole was a central character
and throughout our research and
throughout our writing he's perhaps one
of the most intriguing politicians that
we came across in doing all this and he
really struck us as being a man torn
between his better instincts about what
needed to be done about the deficit a
problem that he helped to create back in
the early 80s and what he needed to do
to
try to advance his own political career
when he ran for president again and
again there was no better example of
this I think then when he tried to get
the balanced budget amendment through
the Senate in nineteen early nineteen
ninety-five you may you only remember
this that that battle Gingrich had
already pushed it through the house and
dole now had to show that he was he was
a revolutionary leader too he was kind
of a can-do guy who could get tough
legislation through and thus deserved to
be the Republican presidential nominee
but the Senate was really a very
different place than the house and dole
was a very different kind of leader than
Gingrich leading the Senate was I think
the best way of describing is trying to
herd cats I mean you've got 99 other
very independent-minded politicians each
with his own agenda each with enormous
power to essentially bring the the
institution to a standstill and
certainly to block legislation that they
don't like now don't get me wrong Bob
Dole was was no shrinking violet but he
was reluctant on very tough votes to
make a personal appeal to members
particularly people he had worked with
colleagues he'd worked with for many
years he don't never left any doubt how
he wanted his members to vote but he was
reticent really to kind of twist arms
sometimes he use humor or a nod or a
grunt or something to sort of get across
his point for example if he were to come
across a member in the hallway who he
knew was opposing an amendment that dole
wanted very badly rather than
buttonholing them and you know talking
his ear off the way Lyndon Johnson might
have done for example dole would go I
yeah I as in vote I when the time comes
you know senators were wondering what is
with this guy but that was sort of dole
style mark Hatfield who served with dole
for a quarter century remembered it
as all light touches with this marvelous
humor that he has but with the balanced
budget amendment it was a very different
situation dole had to get it passed he
believed that is his presidential
aspirations really hung on the on the
outcome of that vote and that losing it
would be a terrible and perhaps
politically fatal embarrassment and here
was Mark Hatfield a fellow Republican
longtime friend chairman of the
Appropriations Committee he was the one
person really standing in the way of
passage of the balanced budget amendment
dole needed one more vote to get the
two-thirds majority that was needed on
the constitutional amendment the
Democrats were all locked into their
position if Hatfield could be persuaded
to change his vote they could they could
get the the 67th vote and passed the
constitutional amendment so it was an
incredibly important moment for for dull
and this is what we wrote in the privacy
of Hatfield's office deep in the
elaborate appropriation sweet duel now
openly pleaded with his friend to change
his mind Mark Duell said this is going
to be a reflection on your leader dole
told him how important it was to him in
his run for the presidential nomination
if he lost this vote it could be
crushing to his campaign which was built
on the notion that he was a leader who
could get things done isn't there any
way you could do this duel beg them the
ordinarily private and self-contained
dole had never appeared to him on such
personal had never appealed to him on
such personal grounds never made himself
so vulnerable it was the most personal
conversation the two men's had had in a
quarter century together in the Senate
and had filled felt terrible anguish at
having to say no they talked through the
options such as Hatfield simply ducking
the vote but the Oregon Senator said he
could not do that either dolci more and
more distressed than Hatfields tundle he
said there is an option that is I'll
write my resignation from the Senate
you'll have 66 of six of 99 votes that's
two-thirds of majority you'll pass the
bill dole reacted at first as if he
didn't understand
and it was an extraordinary sacrifice
Hatfield was willing to walk away from
the office he had held for 28 years give
up the chairmanship of one of the most
powerful committees in Congress go into
retirement just as Republicans were on
the verge of remaking government all to
bail out his friend and spare the party
the embarrassment of losing the vote
when dole gathered his wits he said
firmly of course not I wouldn't consider
that that's that's not an option it was
now no doubt where Hatfield stood
characteristically dole sought to
lighten things again as he stood up well
we're still a half hour away from the
vote dole said wryly maybe you'll change
your mind after dual left half-filled
felt deeply moved we wear masks around
here so much he said later for someone
literally to take off their masks and
say Here I am in a vulnerable position I
think is probably the highest tribute
one human can extend to another human
being when some other human beings says
i need you i desperately rely upon you
at this point is of such vital
importance to me it was a moment of
anguish that I treasured here was this
man really so open so real so sincere I
had a reaction four days after like
someone hit in the stomach I just want
to leave you with one more thing before
we wrap it up Eric likes those poignant
scenes I like the violent horns and
hey there's there's one other thing you
know can you tell we've shifted from you
know for a while you're an author and
it's very pure and it's sublime and
you're locked away in your in your attic
and writing and then you get out and you
become a naked self promoter it's
terrible wait we had one other thing in
out the very end of the budget
negotiations 95-96 January 96 is cold
outside everybody's exhausted they've
been doing this for months they have a
sense that it's not going to work that
the Republicans and Democrats alike are
exhausted and tired but Republicans are
even more tired frustrated angry and
annoyed even at each other and they're
bickering and fighting and so on and so
forth oval office one day there's an
offer on the table and the Republicans
get out they get up and they say okay
we're going to go out and talk about
this and they go out and they caucus for
a while and a while turns into a longer
while and then they're out and hours go
by and the Democrats get the sense that
the Republicans are out there on purpose
staying out just to try to make them
make the Democrats sweat you know if
you've ever bought a car you know at
some point the car salesman gets up and
walks away and he's away for 20 minutes
and a half an hour and anyway the
Republicans were fighting among
themselves they were yelling at each
other and there was an unhappy kind of a
camp at that point they were trying to
decide how far to go whether their
tactics were correct and they were
probably wondering at the time what the
Democrats were doing in the Oval Office
while they were waiting for them to come
back and thinking you know maybe that we
hope they're really discussing their
tactics and thinking maybe we did the
wrong thing in fact what we found that
happened was that as soon as the
Republicans walked out the door Clinton
called up and ordered some popcorn he
flipped on the TV he turned to the
American movie classics channel and he
found a movie Western actually called
rough night and Jericho stirring Dean
Martin right and gene Simmons and as the
Republicans were waiting out there and
trying to make him sweat Clinton SAT
back and they were all enjoying the
movie and Clinton kept saying God that
gene Simmons looks good doesn't she
so when I would say were you happy to
take a few questions and then we'll get
the signing some books there's some
seats up here why don't some of you come
up we have about 10 12 seats up here
come on in so you won't have to crowd
back in the back don't be shy we'll wait
for you come on we're going to stand
here until some of you come up and sit
down it makes us uncomfortable to watch
you all standing back there their loads
of seats on the side you can't see them
from back there they're more over here
impossible you finally prevailed on my
wife to come out versus is it a good
stuff yeah that's good there's seeds
here their seats over here there's a lot
of comfortable seats over here on the
side here can I get some more of you to
come up all right okay anybody have any
questions yes sir could you give us some
idea about what percent of the federal
budget the deficit constitutes I mean is
that 160 billion deficit is it one
percent is at 10.5 if it were 160 would
be about ten percent of the the the
federal budget rotten runs roughly a
trillion six 1.6 trillion now it's down
to about a hundred billion dollars and
really the measurement that most
economists like to use is they compare
it it's like having a mortgage and you
compare your mortgage to your income and
what they do is typically they compare
them that you know the dollar figure is
a lot less relevant than the comparison
of the size of the deficit to the gross
domestic product which is a measure of
the size of the economy and now
interestingly enough the deficit has
come down to in terms of that comparison
which sort of
measures how fordable it is to the
economy into the nation at large to
about 1.4 percent of GDP which means
translated it's as low as it's been
since Nixon was president but compared
to the federal budget compared to the
federal budget now let's see what would
be a hundred can anybody do this math on
top of their head if 160 out of 1.6
trillion is ten percent than this the
deficit would be what about six six
percent roughly six percent of the size
of the other federal budget is borrowed
money which is not gigantic obviously
yeah the point being that is getting
pretty small yes well just following
that up as a debt owed owed by the
American people isn't it more meaningful
to compare to the gross domestic product
in terms of the debt the size of the
overall debt no the deficit oh yeah
right yes yeah yeah and yeah and this is
again at the comparison we use in the
book a little bit as the size of a
mortgage and you know for a mortgage
obviously $100,000 mortgage for Donald
Trump is chickenfeed $100,000 mortgage
for somebody's making fifteen thousand
dollars a year as a killer so that's the
relevant way to think about it I think
Jen in your interviewing process when
you were talking about the main players
it seems that in terms of the deficit
the American public in fact is not a
mean did you have anything did you do
any interviewing of whether your average
Joe on the street you know gives a look
about the deficit when we looked at a
lot of polling and we found essentially
a conflicted public and I think this is
one of the big challenges for
politicians and why they seem to be
chasing their tail all the time on the
deficit everyone is for a balanced
budget you know even and everyone wants
the government to live within its means
well you know most Americans of course
don't in this very plastic society and
everyone has a mortgage and car alone
and all this stuff but they want the
government to live within its means yet
you ask them what sacrifices they're
willing to make and then whoa oh no wait
a minute let's not let's not get carried
away you know don't touch my Social
Security don't
that's my Medicare don't don't touch my
Medicaid don't touch veterans benefits
don't do this don't you know don't get
into that subsidy and I think these
mixed signals is made it very difficult
for politicians over the years to
basically pursue a coherent policy it's
much easier to cater to the whims and
more venal instincts of their
constituents then to sort of stick to
their guns when they know in doing
deficit reduction that all the political
pain is is now I mean you will suffer
the consequences almost immediately of
your vote the payoff the benefit is long
term it may not be seen for 15 or 20
years it's very subtle in some ways it
might affect the long-term standard of
living maybe it will increase savings I
mean they're all these things that are
kind of nebulous when you want to know
what what is the bottom line right now
so that's why it's very difficult for
politicians to sort of commit themselves
now to stuff that may not be may not pay
off for many years to come I was going
to ask about the passage that you read
which I thought was very interesting
actually and just sort of a a writing
research in question it just seems to me
there were probably only two people in
the room at the time and my guess is the
source was not up don't know I'm sort of
interested you know was it hard to get
this story from Hatfield or staff or
couldn't like not wait to tell you this
I know it was interesting adul alluded
to it very briefly in a press conference
or on meet the press or something like
that that he had talked to half filled
in his office and we had talked to some
aids trying to get a sense of you know
what was going on and you know we we
felt it was vital to try to bring the
story to life and we didn't want to
write sort of a dry textbook kind of
thing and so I spent a lot of time
trying to arrange for an interview with
with Hatfield finally I got the call and
and I rushed to his his office in
the capital and I was ushered in and he
was on the phone for about 15 minutes
and then he sat down and he is really a
lovely man if you've ever met him he's a
real gentleman and very thoughtful and I
was sort of shocked by how Frank he was
I was disarmed by it and I said well you
know I was kind of apologetic and sort
of probing and asking you know what
really went on in that meeting and he
just sort of laid it out for me and then
he in this very passionate way and when
I was done I just couldn't believe it
and then George and I talked it over and
over again and we thought we really have
to bring this to life because most
people don't know that much about Bob
Dole I mean I think he's a very
difficult man to read and we all covered
him on the hill and in many ways he's
inscrutable I mean he's you know great
with one line quips but didn't in while
he held a lot of press conferences he
really didn't let his guard down and so
it was very difficult to to get much out
of him I interviewed and interviewed him
several times for the book and I can't
say that any of them were really
satisfactory types of interviews because
well for one thing we were pressing him
on trying to recall stuff that happened
a long time ago I mean I don't know
about GOI have trouble sometimes
recalling what I did you know two weeks
ago let alone you know in 1981 when they
were fighting over supply-side economics
and all that but also he's very cautious
guy and so I talked to him a little
about it but didn't get much from him
and then half-filled just opened up and
so we had this wonderful scene and we
just sort of did as much with it as we
good yes without approving or
disapproving why do you think paul
tsongas his approach was given so little
attention during the campaign for
example good campaigner shine I mean why
why did people spend a pay so little
attention to what Paul Tsongas was
talking about how not so much what he
was talking about but the approach that
he and his committee well I think that
those Paul Tsongas and members of the
Concord Coalition are true budget hawks
deficit hawks and they firmly believe
that the biggest problem facing America
today is a runaway deficit of course the
deficit has gone down in recent years it
seems less of a threat although
certainly if you look at the projections
in the coming century it's kind of
alarming how the deficit will shoot up
unless Congress does something more on
entitlements but I think that Tsongas
who I think began his career as a
liberal and then gradually became more
and more conservative in his in his
views especially on tax policy it was a
big believer in the importance of tax
breaks for to simulate the economy to
help business especially small business
in his hometown but also he believed you
know he believed fervently in this and
when he ran for president he was in 1992
he was the only Democrat out there
talking about deficit the deficit
problem and what needed to be done Bill
Clinton wasn't talking about it he was
running away from the issue bob kerrey
another Democrat who was running for the
Democratic nomination that year told us
you know he stayed away from talking
about the deficit he said there were no
applause lines in it why bother there
were no votes in it I mean who wants to
run particularly in a recessionary
wracked New England you know during the
during the that campaign talking about
painful cuts that have to be made you
know increasing taxes on the middle
class cutting programs all these things
were not nothing things that help you
get nominated president but but Tsongas
sort of stuck to his guns and early on
it looked as if it was paying off early
on it appeared as if Frank talk really
was paying off for him in in New England
but after after winning in New Hampshire
the Democratic primary primarily because
Clinton had so many problems of his own
you know sex scandals and stuff like
that gradually Clinton was able to
bloody Tsongas by raising but by taking
challenging him on a lot of his
proposals and showing that these painful
solutions that he was talking about were
not all that popular with most Americans
yep do you have any reaction of the book
excuse me the Forbes campaign no he came
it came a little late for us to sort of
incorporate that and that was more or
less than they we kind of cut off the
book in January of 96 and of course
Forbes was active at the time but we
focused on the end game of the budget
negotiations and then stopped we were
exhausted so our next book will deal
heavily with the Forbes game they would
be a couple more questions so what's the
sides and what's the role of corporate
welfare however you define it I think
that I think that Congress the
Republican Party in particular
struggling with this issue right now I
think that the one of the problems is
defining what corporate welfare is I
think that a lot of Republicans
including John Kasich who are concerned
that to be fair in dealing with the
deficit major businesses and special
interests are going to have to bear
their their their share of the burden
but i think the republicans for the most
part are trying to focus on spending
programs in subsidies but they're
they're reluctant to go after some of
the big tax breaks that help major
corporations in promoting their their
products overseas or getting a leg up on
research or the scores of other benefits
i think that you'll see probably more
and more emphasis on it as a coalition
around this begins to expand but i don't
expect to see any major inroads along
those lines anytime soon
just open Georgia higher again it's
clear that the Republicans weren't
prepared for the as well politically for
the shutdown but in talking to the
administration folks did you get a sense
from them that they were just waiting to
hit this out of the park or were they
were they nervous as well because it's
clear that's that's a turning point you
know that's that's a very good question
and I don't know if we can
satisfactorily answer that despite
having talked to a lot of people in the
administration about that I think they
they felt very concerned the first time
through because they were in really
terra incognita they didn't know what
was going on and they were just as
desperate to reopen government at that
point during that first one around
Thanksgiving I think it was right
November right before Thanksgiving in 95
as the Republicans were I remember one
time they said Leon Panetta came up
desperately frantically searching for
John Kasich in the house gym and looking
for him everywhere and they were sitting
around the thing they were worried about
they hadn't got the poll results yet
which I think buoyed them considerably
and made them rethink this whole
strategy but they were very worried
because they were going to lose a vote
in the house very soon and that first
shutdown they were going to lose control
of their own people and they were going
to be embarrassed in fact the day that
the language was faxed back from the
Capitol giving them a way out of the
shutdown they were sitting around sort
of moping about how are we going to spin
this how are we going to you know once
we lose control of our own party in the
house and they vote to to reopen the
government in some fashion and we have a
choice of whether or not to be taught
what are we going to do then I think
once they saw the poll results of course
that showed them winning two to one and
public opinion on that question of who
caused the shutdown they took a much
decidedly more sanguine view I just just
to follow up on that I just had a
question about how medic Medicare as a
particular program seemed to generate
and there seemed to be a lot of support
among the polling respondents at least
the for that program and yet now oh and
I remember thinking at the time how I
mean there are real problems with
Medicare and keeping it solvent over the
course of several
it's in the future so how was Quentin in
his second term which he now has going
to tackle this and I reading the post
today I think code one of you wrote the
story about others an 18 billion dollar
compromise but but I don't know if there
are any details with regards that in
other words Clinton is hat is having to
grapple with the making reductions in
spending in Medicare right what well I
think they I mean everyone seems to
agree that you have to we have to do
something about Medicare spending the
there's still a big the Republicans and
Democrats still are very far apart on I
think on on Medicare not not only on the
numbers but although the gap is
decreasing but also sort of the policy
how you go about doing it I think the
the administration early on seemed
anxious to do something in a big way
about the problem short term and then
long term and there was talk a member of
creating some kind of a commission blue
ribbon commission to look at the
long-term problems and come up with
recommendations for restructuring it
while doing something this year to make
sure that the system doesn't go bankrupt
in the next several years the whole idea
of the Commission is just sort of
disappeared I think Clinton for the time
being is simply interested in doing just
enough to get by and there isn't a lot
of enthusiasm on either side of the
aisle to do anything dramatic on
entitlements on cost-of-living
adjustments the whole range of things
that affect entitlement program seniors
in veterans group so I think you'll see
some some incremental steps along the
way but nothing bold